in his history play Henry V
Shakespeare pays tribute to the medieval
English king who risked it all by
Leading a small exhausted Army to
victory over heavily armed French
Cavalry at the Battle of Agincourt
briefly uniting the two kingdoms
fittingly Henry's decision to mount a
Chansey military Expedition is catalyzed
by an enemy's challenge to a game of
tennis
in the play's opening scene Henry is in
consultation with the Barons and leading
Bishops of his realm the latter are
trying to convince them to resume the
wars in France while the former either
urged him to refrain or to fight the
rebellious Scots closer to home
no arguments have won the day when Henry
calls in the Ambassador sent from the
doe Fung The Heir Apparent to the French
throne and Henry's own cousin the
Ambassador delivers his master's message
your highness legally sending into
France did claim some certain dukedoms
in the right of your great predecessor
King Edward III in answer of which claim
the prince our Master says that you
Savor too much of your Youth and bids
you be advised there's not in France
that can be with a Nimble galliard one
you cannot revel into dukedums there he
therefore sends you meet her for your
spirit this ton of treasure and in lieu
of this desires you let the dukedoms
that you claim hear no more of you
this insolent speech alludes to Henry's
misspent teenage years when as plain old
Hal he had roved and reveled in the
Streets of London frequenting its
taverns and gaming tables with his band
of disreputable buddies but Hal is Harry
now and King of England tight-lipped at
this insult Henry asks his uncle the
Earl of Exeter to open the Dothan's
treasure chest and tell him what it
contains Exeter replies
tennis balls my liege
Henry responds
we are glad the dofan is so pleasant
with us his present and your pains we
thank you for when we have matched our
rackets to these balls we will in France
by God's grace play a set shall strike
his father's Crown into the hazard tell
him that he hath made a match with such
a Wrangler that all the courts of France
will be disturbed with chases
ing on the language of the dofa's
proposed game Henry shows off his
knowledge of its rules and strategies
how he will Dazzle onlookers with his
racket work and eventually strike the
French king's crown into the hazard
sending it out of bounds he will
moreover take all the courts of France
tennis courts and princely courts by
storm aiming his shots so skillfully
that no opponent will be able to return
those chases
this episode I should clarify is not a
mere fiction invented by Shakespeare for
dramatic effect in Holland Church
Chronicles a massive digest of English
History that was the main source for
this and other history plays we read
that the future Charles VII the one who
would owe his crown to Joan of arc's
Championship had antagonized Henry by
sending him a gift of quote Paris balls
the game called real real or Royal
tennis was indeed invented in 12th
century France then a tiny Kingdom
centered on Paris originally it had been
a type of handball a Jude poem and it
continued to be played by striking the
ball with the palm of the hand in many
locales for centuries
this was obviously a very convenient and
inexpensive Pastime all you needed was a
ball and an opponent or a wall but in
Paris players began to use special
paddles or rackets in order to hit the
ball harder and with greater accuracy
the word tennis May derive from the
morning meaning look out or heads up
that signaled a service at the beginning
of a match the terminology of tennis
today still contains traces of its
medieval French Origins thus love is
luff the egg zero
tennis games could be played Outdoors on
a lawn or in a cloistered or enclosed
space but medieval French Aristocrats
and those who wish to emulate them began
to construct specially equipped courts
with galleries for spectators to sit
comfortably
it is estimated that there were hundreds
of such courts in Paris Alone by the
16th century when Henry VII of England
took over Cardinal woolsey's Grand
Palace of Hampton Court in 1530 he
remodeled it to include a tennis court
and to establish himself as a keen
player and rival to his French
counterparts and Berlin was reportedly
watching a game of tennis when she was
arrested on May 2nd in 1536 alas for her
that does not appear to have been a
tennis court in the Tower of London
tennis was thus the original sport of
Kings long before yachting and horse
racing one lovely allusion to its Royal
associations comes from a famous early
English Christmas comedy known as the
second Shepherd's play second because it
follows a more conventional play about
the Nativity of Jesus in its sole
surviving manuscript we looked at one
scene in our survey of The King's
English
in the play a trio of pastoral bumpkins
are tricked by Mack the Sheep stealer
and his wife Jill Who hide the
shepherd's prized lamb in a cradle and
pretend it's a newborn child
the Shepherds eventually discover their
mistake but their Simple Kindness toward
the baby sheep is rewarded by the
revelation of a real baby Jesus to whom
they offer the only poor gifts they have
a bird a bunch of cherries and a tennis
ball
each of these homely objects is also
richly symbolic the bird is the Holy
Spirit the cherries represent the Virgin
birth and reference a popular medieval
Christmas Carol about Mary's discovery
of her Divine pregnancy and the tennis
ball is a fitting tribute to the king of
Heaven
the shepherd's speech as he presents it
to the Christ child is achingly sweet
and tender
Heil darling dare full of godhead I pray
thee be nearer when that I have made
hail sweet is like sheer my heart would
blade to see they sit here and so poor
Wade with no pennies hell put forth I
Dal I bring me but a ball have and play
thee with all and go to the tennis
closely related to tennis but much more
ubiquitous and popular than as now are
the many kinds of football developed and
played throughout Medieval Europe often
involving entire Villages pitted against
one another
of course kicking and hitting balls are
pastimes as old as Humanity but there is
pretty straight line to be drawn from
what we know about medieval football and
the modern sport including the use of
goal posts or Nets to Mark the scoring
of points
it's even been suggested that the
doorways or balconies of Parish churches
at either end of a Town Square could
have been used for the goals of rival
teams
the carved underside of a wooden misery
cord that is the merciful little wooden
seat that a weary monk or chorister
could perch on during a long church
service depicts two young men from
opposing sides skirmishing over a ball
in this example from the English
Cathedral of Gloucester the boys are
warmly dressed and wearing hoods
suggesting that their match was part of
a game associated with the winter
holidays this is corroborated by a
famous description of medieval London
and its sports or Ludi a Latin word that
has the same range of meanings as our
English synonyms for any type of game or
play
a highlight of the year was a festive
football tournament played by all the
city's Lads on shrove Tuesday Mardi Gras
which marked the end of the Carnival
season the description is featured in
the earliest biography of Saint Thomas
Beckett who had been born and raised in
London and must have participated in
these activities as a boy and here's a
quotation
after midday all the use of the city go
out into the fields to take part in a
ball game the students of each school
have their own balls the workers from
each City craft are also carrying their
balls older men fathers and Wealthy
citizens on Horseback come to watch the
youngsters competing and to relive their
own youth vicariously you can see their
inner passions aroused as they watch the
action and get caught up in the fun
being had by the Carefree adolescents
in fact as we would expect from the
passions roused by football matches
today medieval authorities often move to
ban these games at times of urban unrest
or particularly bitter rivalries between
teams in the 14th century for example
the Oxford coroner had to investigate
the circumstances in which a student had
been killed in the course of a football
game between his friends and a group of
Irish students this could mean either
that this form of the game was more
dangerous like the rough sport later
associated with the grammar school
founded at rugby in the 16th century or
that something had occurred during the
game to become a catalyst for violence
in 1314 to take another example the
mayor of London issued a decree
prohibiting a variety of sports and
pastimes that were known to disturb the
peace on the grounds that King Edward II
was embarking on a war against the Scots
and had charged his officials to
maintain order in his absence
as a result the carrying of arms was
forbidden within City walls even for use
in fencing schools and there was a
specific ban on football games the
decree originally in anglo-french reads
and because there is great uproar in the
city due to certain rajari de gross
pelot to pay that is big heated football
matches being played on common land from
which many evils can arise from time to
time he forbade that these games be
played within the city precincts
however the wording of this injunction
would have been a clear indication to
his listeners that it was okay to play
outside the city across the Thames where
other forbidden looty were traditionally
allowed
ball games as a test of skill and
accuracy could also take the form of
bowling for which there are terms in a
range of medieval languages
and a related category of sports
involved competitive projectile throwing
from horseshoes to hammers to coits
these games too could go awry another
Coroner's report this one from London in
1275 reported the two friends called
John futard and John Leclerc quote were
playing together with their tiles in the
churchyard when the latter throwing the
tile in his turn and quite against his
own will struck the said John futard on
the right side of the head making a
wound two inches long and penetrating to
the brain
this unfortunate John died six days
later there is no record of the verdict
against his friend but it was probably
ruled involuntary manslaughter
board games and games of chance were
also of enormous importance during this
period crowned by that other medieval
sport of Kings chess
in my earlier lecture on accounting and
risk we were introduced to the
checkerboard cloth of the English
exchequer where counters representing
sums of money were tallied and stacked
games of checkers or drafts also using
counters have been played for much of
human history but it was only in the
Middle Ages that this board became the
stage of Epic and sometimes never-ending
or unresolved battles between two Royal
miniature armies
the earliest written accounts of Chess
in medieval Sanskrit and middle Persian
give it similar names chaturanga in
Sanskrit and satrang in Persian both
referring to the four limbs or divisions
of an army which in those lands included
elephants and chariots or camels as well
as Cavalry and Infantry
the names for chess and Arabic and Greek
are obviously related and zatrician
the Latin term ludus kakoram or scotchi
and its vernacular derivatives had been
tied to a different Persian word Shah
King yielding both check and chess
the etymology of mate is more contested
with some historical linguists pointing
to the Persian mate which means helpless
or abandoned While others related to the
Arabic is dead
that chess had already been well
established in the medieval
Mediterranean World by the early 11th
century is clear from a letter of
complaint written by Peter Damien a
theologian and Bishop of ostia the port
of Rome in which he officiously informs
another high-ranking Churchman that he
had happened upon the bishop of Florence
absorbed in a game of chess Damien had
rebuked his fellow bishop and insisted
that church canons forbidding games of
chance like dice also applied to chess
but gerardus the Florentine Bishop so
accused retorted the chess was a game of
skill
another early indication of the game's
adoption in Italy is the so-called chess
set of Charlemagne made from elephant
Ivory which actually dates from the 11th
century and is thus contemporary with
Peter Damien's anecdote the famous Lewis
Chessman found on that hebridean island
in Scotland are made of walrus Ivory and
were probably crafted in Norway during
the 12th century evidence of how quickly
the game had traveled from the
Mediterranean to the northernmost
reaches of Europe
as just took hold in medieval Europe the
distinctive appearance of its pieces
their movements and the rules of the
game began taking on the forms familiar
today via a relatively rapid process of
codification that indicates how
widespread and Universal the game had
become
European influence is most significant
in the substitution of the queen for the
figure of the vizier the advisor or
fixer of a king who could only move one
square diagonally at a time
this replacement had begun to occur by
the beginning of the 11th century with
the word vizier becoming an old French
fear Proud Lady within the next few
centuries moreover the queen had become
the most powerful figure on the board
moving fluidly and mirroring the tricky
movements of a powerful woman's
political maneuvers
in addition to the king the most stable
pieces over time were those of the
horsemen or Knight and pawn whose
deliberate but vulnerable pacing matched
the slow movements of medieval
infantrymen meanwhile in Europe the
Asian elephant became a bishop in
English a fool in French or a Herald
Alfieri in Italian but its role remained
the same The indo-persian Chariot or
Arab camel Rook became in Europe LaRoche
or Rook reflecting the new importance of
fortified castles in the 11th century
indeed it's clear that part of chess's
Allure derived from the ways that it
mimicked or commented on the roles of
various categories of people in medieval
society which made chess a metaphor not
only for Warfare and kingship but for
political strategy business dealings and
seduction
chess games are featured in thousands of
extant medieval artworks from Ivory
carvings to manuscript illuminations to
love poems chess was also an apt
allegory for life lessons in the 13th
century a Dominican Friar called yakopo
of Chase Olay an aptly named town in the
Piedmont region of Italy composed a
Latin Treatise entitled on human morals
and Noble duties according to the game
of chess
a text which was soon translated into
French as Le Judes
the moralized game of chess
yoga po offers a fanciful origin story
for the game claiming that it was
invented by a Greek philosopher in
probably named Xerxes
according to the Middle English
translation of William caxton published
in 1474 the philosopher wanted to quote
teach the manners and conditions of
kings of Nobles and of the common people
and of their offices and how they should
be touched and drawn that is handled and
influenced end quote the philosopher
also wanted to teach the reader how he
should amend himself and become virtuous
after explaining the setup and rules of
the game yakopo then devotes a section
of the text to the role of each piece
and how it teaches us about its human
counterpart in society he even gives
each Pawn a separate identity
corresponding to the types of commoners
in a medieval city-state laborers Smiths
notaries Merchants Physicians innkeepers
Watchmen and entertainers
then goes on to discuss the virtues and
vices common to each class of people and
the ways that a good ruler can make laws
and use his influence for the betterment
of society
a gorgeously illuminated copy of this
work now in the Vatican Library shows
yakopo preaching from a Pulpit adorned
with a large chessboard and his audience
wrapped with interest
many representations of medieval chess
matches suggest that the game was also a
spectator sport and an opportunity for
players to perform and show off the
newest Fashions the success of the
Netflix series the Queen's Gambit
suggests that not much has changed in
this regard either
in one illumination a lavishly dressed
party of young people watched two of
their number play a game for apparently
high stakes and older men in the
background hoists a sack full of money
on which the female player casts an
anxious glance her pet squirrel at her
feet
her male opponent reaches for a piece on
the board as his little dog Snuffles
around him and a tense couple she with
her arms folded he hugging her from
behind are mirrored by a couple on the
left both equally riveted on the game
she whispering in his ear on the far
right of this image another man has his
sword out and is making eye contact with
the older man wielding the sack another
indication that a lot is riding on the
outcome of this game
the association of chess with gambling
which was hugely popular at all echelons
of medieval Society helps to explain the
discomforture with which Elite clergy
regarded this past time especially if it
were played for money or Wagers
as noted above Peter Damien had accused
a fellow Bishop of engaging in a sinful
act when he played a game of chess he
had even warned that canon law allowed
for the deposition of dicing Bishops
Alia Torres episcopy but the accused
cleric was indignant in his own defense
saying one is chess the other is Dice so
if that church Authority prohibited dice
it must have allowed chess precisely
because it remains silent about it
to which retort Damian had fired back
chess I said to him isn't cited in the
scriptures either but the word dice
includes both types of games
and Peter Damien may have been correct
in this some Scholars have suggested
that the earliest form of Chess as
played in India had involved the flowing
of dice it may be that this practice
continued to be a variant of the game as
it made its way Westward the first
detailed description of the game
certainly shows that it could be adapted
in many different ways this account
comes from an extraordinary illuminated
manuscript the Libro de las juegos or
book of games compiled for Alfonso the
tenth El Sabio the wise king of Castile
and completed at the Royal scriptorium
in 1283.
because of the close ties between this
Kingdom and the Muslim polities of
alandalus and Alfonso's well-documented
campaign to Translate Arabic texts into
the Castilian vernacular this compendium
is very likely to preserve oral and
written gaming Traditions passed down
for centuries
for example it includes the earliest
known description of backgammon as well
as in illustration and description of
nine men's Morris a game similar to
Tic-tac-toe and dating back at least to
ancient Rome where it was popular among
soldiers and common people because the
board could be quickly sketched in the
dirt and any small objects could be used
as playing pieces
this Deluxe codex begins with a story
honoring the genealogy of Chess which is
said to have been invented by an Indian
philosopher king a more plausible
version of the tale related by yakopo
who had also stressed the game's moral
and political uses
this manuscript features more than 100
Illustrated chess problems and solutions
as well as variants for multiple players
including a game of astronomical chess
played on a special board representing
the zodiac in its entirety then the book
reflects Alfonso's fascination with
gaming as a dialectical exercise that
pits a player's intelligence and skill
against the forces of Fortune and fate
as well as the Wiles of his opponent
for the many medieval critics of gaming
however there was no such sophisticated
dialectic to justify play dice cards and
other games were condemned as
Blasphemous pastimes that subverted the
order of God's creation and made a
mockery of church doctrine this was a
favorite Topic in the preaching of a
fiery 15th century Franciscan reformer
Bernardino of Siena in one Vivid sermon
fra Bernardino imagines a set of
gamblers as participants in a diabolic
Black Mass the priest is the Devil
Himself and his missile is a set of dice
whose markings are made with his own
excrement the playing cards are the
devil's Breviary just look at them clubs
weapons wielded by crazy Savages cops
for drunkards coins for the greedy and
swords for killers
the two-headed Kings and the Queens are
assorted Lords of misrule turning the
world upside down
rather than offering prayers Gamers sigh
for their losses instead of taking
communion in the Eucharist they become
drunk cries of Glory to God are drowned
out by the groans of losers and the
shouts of I win and when the Unholy
masses ended Bernardino warns you will
see the evil you have done and may
rather than living in Christ kill
yourself in despair
it was thus the Unholy passions aroused
by gambling as well as the iniquities of
gambling and greed that arouse the
preacher's ire and concern a manuscript
illumination from this same period
captures the mood of a dice game that
has clearly inspired intense emotions
among its onlookers and players at least
one of whom seems about to lose his
shirt
dice are not medieval inventions they
are as old in one form or another as
civilization but cards for gaming and
divination do appear to be a medieval
Innovation beginning in China around the
9th century and making their way to
Western Asia by the 11th examples from
medieval Persia suggest that there were
a range of different suits or patterns
with 12 cards originally in each 10 pip
cards and two court cards usually a king
and vizier as in contemporary chess sets
from the region
the oldest surviving deck dating from
the early 15th century and made in Egypt
shows that each suit had by then come to
include 13 cards just like modern decks
with a third figure the vizier's deputy
among the court cards the four most
common suits cups swords coins and
batons are still found in some European
traditions and are also familiar from
Modern tarot cards this word from the
Italian tarochi whose etymology is
obscure was originally another type of
gaming deck supplemented by additional
cards painted with elaborate allegorical
or astrological scenes first documented
in Northern Italy these decks became
known as triomphi or in English trumps
until the invention of printing which
enabled the mass production of cards to
the horror of clerical critics Dex would
have been specially commissioned and
produced for individual patrons a
surviving account from the Allied
duchies of brabant and Luxembourg
records with apparent disapproval that
the Duke and Duchess had paid Assam
amounting to the price of eight and a
half sheep for a mere deck of cards the
oldest extant European sets are the
deluxe remnants of some 15 incomplete
Decks that were made in the mid-15th
century for Filippo Maria Visconti Duke
of Milan whom a contemporary Source
credits with having invented novum
quadum and exquisite news a rather new
and exquisite kind of Trumps
cards from these decks are now dispersed
among many public and private
Collections and they feature designs
resembling the Arcana of modern tarot
decks death the emperor and Empress the
fool the Knight of Cups and so on
the earliest printed decks not
surprisingly were manufactured in some
of the first German towns to set up
printing presses and reveal that many of
the Arabic Persian Latin suits had been
replaced in northern Europe by Hearts
Shields acorns leaves and bells
the oldest complete set of cards from
this period is the Flemish hunting deck
hand-drawn rather than printed with the
suits all featuring hunting themes horns
leashes and collars for hounds and
nooses for game
meanwhile as in chess the Christian
Court cards vizier had become the queen
and his Deputy the knave or Jack
there isn't space here to detail or even
name all of the local gaming variants
and outdoor seasonal sports that
developed throughout the Medieval World
and that are still the traditional focus
of regional festivals and Heritage
reenactments like the Highland Games of
Scotland the very fact that communities
cherish their own forms of play or house
rules that gov that govern local
varieties of sport is a testament to the
enormous importance of play in the life
of every society
and while not all of the games people
played during the Middle Ages were
Medieval in origin it is thanks to
Medieval sources and surviving artifacts
that we know so much about the history
of pre-modern Ludi not incidentally it
is thanks to a medievalist the Dutch
historian johannsinka that we have
recognized scholarly disciplines such as
game studies Game Theory and the history
of sport all derived from his massively
influential book homo ludens first
published in Dutch in 1938
as its title suggests hoisinger regarded
the species homo human to be more
accurately characterized as ludens
playing rather than sapiens
understanding or reasoning this is as he
argued because play is older than
culture and therefore more Elemental to
The Human Condition than other
attributes that have been induced as
essential to human survival such as
speech play hoytzinga insists
constitutes its own form of life not
real life or ordinary life but a state
of freedom and creativity that is
ultimately the generator of all art and
of all that is good in human society
as he put it civilization quote does not
come from play like a baby detaching
itself from the womb it arises in play
and as play and never leaves it
what better way to describe the
longevity and endurance of the games we
still play